this week on the show as our weather
becomes Wilder due to climate change we
look at the government's latest plans to
reach Net Zero which include sucking
more carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere something under the waves
here could help with that
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom peep this week I'm in Sussex
where later in the program we'll be
looking at how a nature recovery beneath
the waves here is not only good for
wildlife but could help climate too but
first it's all about Green Day
not the pop punk Legends of the early
2000s but the government's plans to
reach Net Zero by 2050 which were
revealed on Thursday so what did they
say and how did we get here
Thursday was supposed to be the day
Rishi sunak updated the world on how
Britain will reach Net Zero by 2050.
today we're announcing more investment
in Renewables like offshore wind
Reviving The Nuclear industry developing
new Industries like carbon capture and
storage and as we deliver on that we're
going to create jobs across the country
we're going to increase our energy
security reduce people's bills and
reduce our carbon emissions
it was originally called Green Day but
was rebranded to energy security day
which raised a few eyebrows in the
climate world
the government released a huge number of
documents for the day totaling over 2
800 pages of work but many said the
announcements still fell well short of
what's needed
desired by today's plans and the
Renewables industry as an investor
you're going to look at the UK and look
at it in the context of what the US are
offering the EU offering and you might
just choose to go there instead last
year the High Court ruled the
government's Net Zero strategy unlawful
and Joe Biden published far-reaching
green plans to encourage U.S business to
grow in a more sustainable way the
inflation reduction act
represents the most significant
pro-climate legislation ever passed by
Any Nation in all of history and in
January ex-energy Minister Chris
Skidmore released Mission zero a wide
reaching review of how net zero plans
and businesses could help each other in
the UK I've tried to recast net serum
not as an environmental pleasure but as
an economic one Thursday's announcements
were supposed to be an answer to all
three of those events
well talk about what was Builders Green
Day colors didn't turn out to be that
Vivid in the end I'm joined by Sky's
energy and climate correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter in Sky's electric vehicle
charging base Hannah was it brand new
vehicles brand new stuff or was it a bit
of a respray of things we've seen before
it was actually interesting because one
of the
few ideas came from the Department for
transport who proposed this consultation
on giving a mandate to vehicle
manufacturers to make increasing numbers
of electric vehicles and there were some
new money
made available to increase the EV
charging infrastructure
I was about 300 million for local
charging and residential charging
but there the newness ends the immediate
criticism was this is just reheated
policy already announced stuff coming
out you're packaging it in this shiny
wrapping paper and that's what I asked
Energy Secretary Grant chaps about is
there any new money in the set of
policies ah there is money that is new
in it for example uh we are extending
today uh the scheme which enables people
to fit heat pumps into their homes and
there's a lot of other money is that I
mean look I'm not particularly defensive
about this I think it's a good thing to
to sort of Define the money that you're
going to spend and lay out the detail of
those policies so he was broadly
admitting there wasn't much new in the
showroom here one of the things he's
very keen about still is carbon capture
and storage or carbon capture and
utilization this idea that we can
capture the carbon dioxide and somehow
lock it up keep it away from the
atmosphere yeah and in the budget they
announced 20
over the coming few decades to have a
real go at Carbon capture and storage
let's just be really clear it is
relatively untested we know the
technology works but it's not available
or affordable at scale
the thing that the government really
likes about it actually is that it could
support tens of thousands of new jobs
and they did say that they're going to
concentrate this effort in the
industrial Heartland clusters in the
north north east north west a tea side
near Liverpool and so on so that's why
they're pushing on it of course oil and
gas are keen on it too because it allows
them to keep using their core product
while they reduce the harm of it and I
did press Grant chaps on that issue
people are already capturing carbon we
know that can work I agree there's a big
difference between doing that and
storing 78 tons billion tons of it you
know under under the sea in the North
Sea but if we can make that work then
there's a massive export opportunity to
us probably bigger than oil and gas was
in the first place very clearly not an
open Wallet shelling out money and a lot
of people are contrasting that to what's
been happening in America many more
subsidies there a lot of talk about that
happening in Europe
is there a danger of us kind of losing a
lot of these green jobs green
technologies yes I mean bluntly yeah
exactly exactly that and you know you're
talking about the inflation reduction
act which um President Joe Biden passed
370 billion US dollars
to attract a clean tech investment to
the US to make it a clean energy
superpower the EU has responded in kind
the Renewables industry in the UK has
been so worried about this and they've
been asking for much more favorable tax
environments so that they can keep all
of their investment and efforts here
we've been leading on wind for a decade
and a half they're starting to make
noises that these big projects might be
on the line that are coming down down
the track but is this just the case that
they see another chance to get their
snouts and the subsidy trough I mean
renewable energies love a subsidy
environment don't they who wouldn't who
senior Source at a big Wind Farm
developer
whether there was enough to make them
excited in Green Day and I got a shrug
Emoji back right so yeah not much there
so there's a bit of work to do there
between the relationship between the
government and and big Wind Farm
operators I love the fact that leaks and
Scoops these days come in the form of
emoji they do that's really nice now the
climate change announcements this week
were triggered by the danger of a legal
challenge in the world legal challenge
they said they had to come up with a
sufficient plan by the end of this month
have they done enough or might they end
up in court that's a good question so
yeah this is Friends of the earth and
legal allies forced this additional
detail from the government and by the
end of March so they were right up
against the deadline
and actually once you've got into the
detail of the government's documents you
kind of admitted yesterday that even
with nearly 3 000 pages and 70 separate
policies they were still going to fall
slightly short but they actually
admitted that yeah just by a couple of
percentage points
exactly right now you know Grant shops
did kind of give me some reassurances
that the plan was to hit the targets but
then he said you know everything's in
Touching distance can you promise the
British public that these plans will
deliver Net Zero by 2050 while also
guaranteeing security of Supply yes
that's exactly the plan and the reason
that I'm confident about this is I have
more stake in this than pretty much
anyone else and that's because the
secretary of state is personally
required by law to get us to Net Zero by
2050. that's not a matter of sort of it
would be quite nice to do the ultimate
sanction is that the Secretary of State
can go to prison I think that's the
first time I've heard a minister admit
to being a potential future jailbird
Hannah Thomas Peter thank you very much
indeed thanks Tom
a very useful breakdown from Hannah
there which I'm going to put to Chris
Skidmore who was conservative energy
Minister but also wrote the government's
Mission Zero review at their own request
Chris welcome something that slightly
perplexes me you say that you've spoken
to business folk and they say Net Zero
is a business opportunity the
conservative party claims to be the
party of business why is this so
underpowered well I think the
government's response to my mission zero
report this week it has demonstrated
that they want to power ahead it's just
that they haven't got any new money uh
new investment uh and the decision to
wait also uh of a response from the US's
inflation reduction act uh I think is
regrettable because
um you know time is also money and when
we look at investors now they will be
making business decisions about whether
to come to the UK come to the United
States come to Europe and we needed that
sort of policy certainty and a big bang
moment I think as I called it in the
review and I'm not quite sure we had
more of a sort of damp fizzle uh as a
result of the response uh this week uh I
just only hope that you know we will
recognize the Economic Opportunity that
Net Zero provides but that hasn't been
recognized yet it seems to me not really
in government
well I think compared to where I was
three years ago you know when the
treasury wasn't so prone at zero I think
the treasury now recognized that Net
Zero is the future economy of the UK
they just seem to want to be able to
sort of like sit back and wait for what
the eu's going to do before maybe coming
forward with their trump card uh that's
my hope
and that risks losing a lot of business
doesn't it and losing a position we've
got here I mean it it feels like they
see it more as obligation than
opportunity at the moment I think the
other challenge is is not to sort of
talk down the inflation production act
because you know we're not going to
match which the chancellor did didn't we
yeah yeah and I think that was
regrettable because ultimately there are
closest allies they are democratically
like-minded in terms of thinking about
the future special relationship it could
be a green special relationship where we
can work together in the slipstream of
the inflation reduction act and I hope
that you know when Joe Biden comes to
the UK later this um in April this month
that we might be able to look at how we
can form some kind of partnership around
Net Zero yeah and just where I started
about about being perplexed you say they
haven't done this because of lack of
money but there are some things they
could have done which don't require
money their signals you know onshore
wind why not a signal from the center
that that was going to be more welcome
more encouraged rooftop solo something
that you specifically asked for once
again we didn't hear anything on that
these aren't big Financial things from
the center why didn't they do them no I
think you're right there is a messed
opportunity uh there were some real
positives uh there for me on rebalancing
gas and electricity prices continuing to
set out pathways on the vehicle mandate
you know recognizing uh the opportunity
for solar uh maybe not on rooftops but
it's creating a new solar task force
that would work towards 70 gigawatts of
deployment by 2035. so yes there were
some measures it was a bit Hokey Cokey
half in half out if I'm honest with you
having just done a fridge and 40 page
review I sort of feel everyone's sick of
doing reviews and consultations they
just want to get on with the job also
they've basically admitted that this
doesn't add up yet to reaching Net Zero
there's a paper out towards the end of
yesterday this is a legal obligation as
Grant chapters actually said you know he
could end up in jail should it be should
he be getting ready his uh his his
prison uniform well yeah that's right 92
percent of our NDC Target by 2030 and I
said in the Commons yesterday Net Zero
is not about 2050. it is about 23 T
seven years to go it's not you can't
kick the can down the road thinking oh
this is 28 years until we've got to
achieve it which is why it's so
important that we deploy Technologies of
today yeah the challenge is always yeah
the politicians of today are gone by
tomorrow when actually we need to create
climate Frameworks that mean that people
are held accountable today Chris good
more thanks a lot thank you now one area
of our economy and Industry that will be
very tough to decarbonize is steel
production it's not just the energy
involved but the fact that it uses
coking coal but our economics and data
editor Ed Conway has been looking at a
potential sustainable future for steel
in the UK
now outside it's about five degrees but
in here it's toasty warm because this
bubbling cauldron a ladle as it's called
of Steel is about 1600 degrees maybe
right now that has just come out it's
been created by an electric Arc furnace
which is one of the most extraordinary
things I've ever seen basically bolts of
lightning man-made bolts of lightning
turning solid steel into molten metal
it's just crazy and the noise of it is
extraordinary which is why we've had to
come here to to film this bit now that
is potentially going off to become part
of a car in future the kinds of Stills
here that they make are pretty high
quality
um and it's quite rare actually for
people to get access into here we're
first people in many years to be able to
film inside of of this place
but it's a really significant place
because there aren't many electric art
furnaces around in the UK those things
creating a thunderstorm that make still
and electric hot furnaces May well be
something that's really important for
the future of this businesses why
because when you're creating steel from
Iron through Blast Furnace that creates
an incredible amount of carbon this
produces far far less because using
electricity for the most part and so for
a lot of people this is The Greener
steel that we have in this country and
we need more of these electric Arc
furnaces in the future the problem I
should say that's still created by
electrical furnace the problem is that
it takes an extraordinary amount of
power to make that lightning storm that
turns that steel into molten metal
and then you get into the issue that in
the UK we have really high power costs
so if you're going to be trying to
persuade blast furnaces to turn into
electric Arc furnaces therefore making
or still industry far more green well
then you encounter the issue that we
have really high electricity costs which
makes it well if not challenging then
certainly for someone trying to build
one of these things basically impossible
so it is not simple but this is part of
the debate that we're going through
right now in this country to create a
still industry that is greener than the
one we have at the moment
after the break I'll be looking at kelp
that massive seaweed that used to grow
in great forests offshore here so what's
being done to restore it
[Music]
welcome back now many of you will be
familiar with White Cliffs around parts
of our Coast what you probably don't
know is the whole country used to be
ringed by a forest of seaweed it was a
great habitat for wildlife and stored a
lot of carbon in recent years it's got a
bit pummeled by fishing and also
pollution but now as I've been seeing
here in Sussex there are attempts to
bring it back
just offshore beneath the waves
something is rising from the seabed kelp
once dominated the shallow seas around
our Coast providing both a nursery and a
Haven for so much marine life
but a combination of fishing pressure
and pollution have decimated its realm
here in Sussex just fragments remain
we've been left with only three four
percent of our original kelp habitat
when you get down to an area that small
it's really important that we look after
what we've got and that it is thriving
two years ago 300 square kilometers of
seabed was ruled out of bounds for
bottom trawling a type of fishing often
for scallops that scrapes the sea floor
that added to an existing ban on
dredging and bigger vessels
boats like these keyside in Shore and
Port are barred it's enforced by the
inshore Fisheries conservation Authority
the boat with the orange Hull actually
is a very small scallop dredger that
wouldn't be allowed to fish within that
area the purpose of the zone is to
really ensure that the habitats in those
areas can develop and and be as abundant
and and support as much life as possible
large elements of the industry were very
supportive the trawling sector has been
very compliant with the regulation you
know by protecting these areas that will
benefit the Fisheries outside those
zones
but kelp and other seafloor life are
threatened by something else at once
obvious and stealthy the sea is getting
cloudier murkier with less visibility
for divers and sunlight for plants
back on dry land Marianne glascot
analyzes these threats in her lab it was
all right to open it up absolutely oh
look it's very blue in there very the
blue light accelerates the growth well
tell me what are these other pressures
that kelp is under in this area well
we've got a lot of what we call Coastal
darkening in terms of increased
sediments coming down Rivers suspended
sediment in the coastal area is what
makes the water look gray when you look
out to sea
but much of that is actually coming down
our rivers and through our aquifers and
wouldn't naturally have occurred if we
still had Rivers Meandering and dropping
their their silt and their sediment load
on floodplains so has the channel got
murkier in recent years yes
Kell banned other seaweeds capture
carbon dioxide dissolved in seawater so
just like trees their growth helps to
slow global warming and promoting its
growth is a global Quest
70 tons per hectare per year in a
typical kelp forest and other species
thrive in this rewilding of the ocean
floor the divers are reporting is a huge
expanse of muscle beds that is now
forming on the seabed which never had a
chance to develop before when we had
hauling in place last year these muscle
Beds which was the first time there was
seen were about the size of a tennis
court this year there were a kilometer
in width kelp recovery alongside
thriving Coastal ecosystems aren't just
important for the UK they can help
worldwide by purifying water regulating
ocean acidity releasing oxygen and
slowing erosion but delivering that
demands reducing pollution and fishing
pressure
now at this time of the year Muslims
celebrate Ramadan involving a fast From
Dawn till Dusk but when that fast is
broken particularly at the mosque it
often involves using an awful lot of
plastic in the form of bottles Cutlery
and plates and now some within the
community are calling for a plastic free
Ramadan
Allah has created a perfectly balanced
World on the basis of sustainability
this balance must be maintained by man
acting thoughtfully and justly Ramadan
is often a time when people reflect and
make change to improve their lives on
those around them
our aim
to encourage all Muslims in Crystal to
consider using sustainable methods to
adapt iftar activity
um
on 20th of January this year we held a
workshop at the House of Lords
18 mosques have participated in the
workshop
since we started this campaign our
community is learning to understand the
importance of plastic pollution and how
dangerous it is to us and to our planet
the plastic
from being shows how you can make a
difference
so
no steps too small everyone is important
by doing this small step but bring your
own utensils by contributing to a mosque
water source you are actually helping to
stop this plastic pollution increasing
last week on the show we met the
adventurer Sasha Dench who's following
the migration of Ospreys all the way
from Guinea in West Africa to back here
in the UK some may be coming in across
the South Coast as I speak well now
she's been to the Rio Pongo close to the
Senegal border and said as this
set off on our
following the return journey of the
Ospreys from West Africa and we had to
start with a trip to a town called
buffer and it's near to there where a
famous bird called 4K is one that we
managed to track down previously with
the help of local villagers and their
conservation department
[Music]
now you probably noticed that many of
our partners are wearing military
uniforms and that is because in this
part of the world and in fact many parts
of Africa the original priorities for
conservation were anti-poaching we've
heard from locals that actually hunting
could even be an issue for a bird like
the osprey
okay
hunting has been the focus of
conservation efforts in the past that is
rapidly shifting towards climate change
particularly due to the drop in rainfall
in this part of Africa and so we went to
visit a group who are busy trying to
focus on this in particular through
reforestation projects
completely
so as we're learning the site the 4K is
chosen is on the large ponga river in a
coastal Wetland but with changes in
rainfall there could be changes to come
in 4k's habitat over the coming decade
we're also learning that that change in
rainfall isn't just an issue for hearing
Guinea because actually Guinea is the
water source for three main rivers that
feed most of West Africa
well that's it from here in Sussex but
don't forget you can get all your
climate and environment use on the Sky
News website and app we will be back but
not for three weeks we're taking a
little Easter break back on April the
22nd see you then
foreign